you know I wasn't going to talk about
Star Wars but I guess that I guess that
I will because it is May the fourth and
and never have we seen such a wretched
wretched hive of scum and villainy as
the US Congress apparently but aside
from aside from that you know what you
guys have all seen the trailer for the
new Star Wars movie right oh he hasn't
seen the trailer for the new Star Wars
movie so dang it time now okay so I'm
not going to talk about this just for
Malthus I'm going to skip it just for
Malthus I will give you my one word
reaction to it which is disappointing
disappointing is my one word reaction to
the trailer okay I haven't seen the
movie movies not out yet Malthus calm
yourself down the trailer the trailer is
disappointing I also believe that I
rewatched rogue one and I reviewed rogue
one a few months back and I think I gave
it a little bit short trip because I was
really tired when I saw it I started
like 11 o'clock at night and I was kind
of falling asleep at the time and and I
rewatched it actually on a plane and
it's really good I mean rogue one is
really a first-rate movie it's much much
better than the force awakens the force
awakens does not age well the force
awakens is one of those movies where
when you see it you're like you all
carry like that's pretty good and then
the more you think about it like that
was really not very good and that's
because you realize number one and you
notice at the time but you're so
overwhelmed by the nostalgia of it that
it doesn't matter so much it's exactly
the same plot as the original Star Wars
and then beyond that they destroy your
childhood right okay so I can it do I
need to give spoilers for force with
everyone on earth is he in force awakens
do I need to do that okay so spoiler
alert spoiler alert okay now han Solo
gets killed right it destroys your
childhood hey I grew up where han Solo
was the galaxy's biggest badass and
everyone wanted to be Han Solo right
women wanted him and men wanted to be
him every no-one cared about Luke Luke
was kind of a whiny geek but Han was
awesome and then they turned him in the
force awakens into a bickering divorced
dad who can't deal with his kid you know
he's going to buy it the minute that
princess stupid Leia who hasn't done
anything to develop her four skills by
the way I mean they foreshadow it in in
Empire Strikes Back right Yoda there is
another and then she does nothing with
the force for the rest of her life for
the rest of her life she does zero
things with the force right the end of
Empire Strikes Back Luke talks her with
his mind oh happy day that's the
entirety of what Princess Leia does with
the force for the rest of her entire
life
except for giving birth to apparently
the the next worst person in the
universe so she tells Han that it's time
for a han to go talk to her kid the
minute she says that he should have said
her look lady you go do it but I forgot
the lesson you know you're his mom you
go talk to him why me why do I have to
do it she says go talk to him yeah
that's going to go real well as she's
gonna that's going to be a winner also I
do have to ask why it is that in a
galaxy where people have achieved like
speed no one has a cellphone like well
why is it that nobody can just pick up a
phone and call kylo Ren and be like dude
get your get your bleep together
let me Facebook you will have a
conversation let's get together for
coffee instead I'm going to fly to your
death planet and I'm going to infiltrate
your death planet with ever with all
your friends trying to murder me and
then we'll have a conversation on one of
Star Wars famous walkways okay here's
the rule in Star Wars never have a
conversation on a walkway suspended over
nothing okay always goes wrong never a
good no one has ever had a good
conversation on a walkway suspended
above nothing it just ends poorly for
someone involved it destroys your
child's head again Hans whole thing is
that he's a badass Harrison Ford in real
life is still kind of a badass turning
him into you know like a character the
parents of one of these kids from the
Bad News Bears is really is really nasty
so anyway I hope that the new Star Wars
is better than that rogue one was really
good but unfortunately there can't be
sequels really two rogue one this equal
to Rho one is the actual first Star Wars
film so I guess we're going to have to
live with whatever they give us I just
hope that the last Jedi is not Jar Jar
Binks that's all I hope okay so